[Musik]
die folgende sendung wird vom neuen
subaru lewark zwei meter 4 x 4
präsentieren
[Musik]
in der sauna patrick bartoli die dass
die speckschicht
[Musik]
wird er nach der flucht vom in der
familie zog in der iran sei mit meinem
freund gefahren der gleiche weg wie auf
der flucht 1980 in umgekehrter richtung
wenn es zwei jahre lang vorbereitet doch
acht ländern immer gefahr fünf kilometer
bis zur iranischen grenze zur usa finde
ich bin und wo ich herkomm
1908 erste golfkrieg aus brauchen ist
benny andersen in ein neues leben
angefangen nikolov wachsen und als kv
gemacht
[Musik]
22 7 ist mein vater gestorben
mit nina ließ sich benehmen punkt boni
muss wissen dass keine nur nicht ganz
von vorne anfangen
im iran sabotieren weil das papier
fehlen wie dieses auto und iranische
grenze beschlagnahmt
das ist erst einmal dass die tod von
meinem vater wo im iran bin meinem
vaterland stadt mit unserem auto gut mit
dem taxi
[Musik]
ja ich werde doch talent
lebensjahr
[Musik]
du liest
allianz ihren aussagen
[Musik]
ende
in der moschee el corte sie hatten ist
romano
mal wieder
wir fahren nach teheran zu minder
instagram freundin samira für diese
gebiete fahrt gibt es ihres autor
tamis mit ihrem mann josef zum
iranischer zwerge
prof
[Applaus]
[Musik]
tage vorher
nein es war
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mails zu checken
twitter mit
ok
[Musik]
medlock das mal
ich bin ich auch wieder froh es immer
wieder selber unterwegs und können
fahren und frauen damit auf die spur
dass ich von meiner familie
[Musik]
unterwegs in eine von der
eindrücklichsten steht vor der welt es
fahren in der stadt hätten vater unserer
familie die persische kultur welche
bringen
das sommerferien und 14 ich kann mich
noch gut erinnern wie glücklichen vater
in den rhein
[Musik]
in isfahan treffen die freundin von
samir al-hami
das können sie sie zeigt ist schönheit
für ihre stadt und universität um ein
vater unterrichtet hat
[Musik]
ein
doch manager wissen
denise bahamas kennen weder domini heim
hatte zeller werte in iran wo mit dem
bild über westliche medien so wenig aber
will sich zwar oder bild was sind
innerlich erfährt was ich in mühldorf
lösen wird seebacher echo in der moschee
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das geht es oft unterschätzt ist das
forschen überschwänglich und mann
behinderten fasziniert so krumm gesehen
habe habe sie wirklich denken kann
begeistern
das ist jetzt anders macht dass sie
daran besonders nochmals symbol heißt
salome
[Musik]
vertrieben
so viele regeln geht es in den laden kam
es in den farben gelb rot
ja das sei damals diese einst zum
anstoßen mit auto und dort nicht so aber
ich kenne
[Musik]
es dürfte spur das was von ihnen fort
[Applaus]
also mein vater 1970 71 zwei jahre
sportwissenschafter unterrichtet an der
universität also den lehrer ausbildet
[Musik]
ich weiß wie viel ihr team passion
gemacht hat das ist das live sport
und irgendwie ahnte dass durch da wo ich
weiß es nicht aber mir geht's ja das
freut mich sehr dass ist das mag zu
können
[Musik]
stock
und mami
[Musik]
super
die 7
[Musik]
mal über das kind sie das nicht die
fortschritte sind dafür floss weiter
durch noch so etwas sind einfach die 30
wunderschöne viel darum heißt csc pohl
das heißt also müssen der oma club
vereint eine untere unter den blue chips
liegt hat der fluss castlereagh ist
einfach weil er gerade weil jetzt kann
man da auf dem grund von fluss um
einander auf den start allerdings erst
nach zwei drei tagen wieder was das
konto gott dass wir irgendwo gestaut
aber sie haben wassernotstand bei mir an
und fast schon ins bild ein
[Musik]
mainz vor der samen verabschiedet und
fahren nach der 3
dort wohnt der user von frauen bei die
alle fans gelang nötig sei
[Musik]
sie müssen ja irgendwo im nirgendwo und
das heißt beherrscht
das paradies glauben
[Musik]
die maschinen seien aber gerade sein
cyberport enorm
[Musik]
prof
da wird es mal an der aktion kommen
[Musik]
das schade dass ich jetzt
salah badi
[Applaus]
weil man schon morgen um den
mit der iranischen revolution ist
atlanta bruder verteilt worden
ein verwandter ist es lieber hinter
bliebe
[Musik]
ihnen
goodman
[Musik]
das ist
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
saisontor
weil die helios st
man habe sogar mit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir fahren ließ kilometer wird zum
ehemaliger familie landsitz der vater in
der jugend glückliche zeit verbraucht
die ministerin regte mit meinem vater im
iran
[Musik]
schade dass für familien
gebraucht kostet man mit seinem
bekannten als familie waren pure
[Musik]
jackie und jermaine denke ich hat er
sieht das der familie brannte komisch
durch dort laden das reformgesetz in der
ak 40 und liebe damen farbton aktie aber
mit 14
aber da jetzt noch viele mehr das immer
davor das ist alles neue gemein betrieb
sie als gast kam als kind hinter felix
sie dennoch irgendwo markus danuser
fußpedal vorsorge schon großvater ist
die chance aufrecht erhalten bleibt
das ist so vorstellte sieht dass das
nicht wieder familie zusammen und schon
krachte
der wahnsinnige familiengeschichte große
familie gesehen
denn viele sind groß grundsätzen sie und
wenn man heute noch
[Musik]
nein das sicher
und was wünschen sie sich unterhalten
wurde einfach weh
[Musik]
das ziel von 3000 1 vor der ganz großen
ziels hauptziel weil es immer da aber
für mich stehen wir bei der letzten
iranische kontaktpunkt sein vater und
römischen tat sie hat leider ohne ändern
würde aber das ist leider über die
vergänglichkeit und
aber das ist für mich nicht mehr
abgeschlossen ich mir mit meinem vater
verbindet
[Musik]
die kindheit in laut verbraucht
wir fahren die strauß sei von ihrer
vergangenheit früheren hochburg sein und
ein klebt
das ist wirklich den regeln von mirial
die glück dass gomez ab sie das
[Musik]
denn mehr genug dass man beobachtet
werden
[Musik]
schüler haben
was eine gute stube sehen dax und jahren
ich glaube da oben oder für die ersten
flocken
es gibt erst mal kontrolliert worden
völlig okay aber mehr sich das defizit
war
[Musik]
freiheit zu entlocken was man will
37 will mich das vielleicht die
wichtigste frage die großartig freiheit
ist und wie hart das sinnlos wenn man
sie nicht hat
samira lüthard erzählt mir dass alle
kontaktpersonen befragt worden
sie birgt aber jetzt fühle ist bedroht
beide seiten werden jetzt in gold paar
jahren in die kiste und ihm so schnell
unser co denn die ganz toll weil er weiß
dass sie glaubt dass ist damit beendet
und ok aber einfach richtig trends vor
der grund der angaben war das bist du
keine chance gewesen
[Musik]
wir gehen
sich sehr schön und familie vom erzähler
familie das mega glücklich das jetzt
machen die kultur und das sie den 20
es ist eine art sport aber es ist gut
dass es jetzt noch
[Musik]
zurück in teheran
diese fühlt sich an der straße
kontrolliert worden sind es leichter
kühl bleibt
[Musik]
david folgendes meinung
berlin
[Musik]
verstehen
dann fragt wieso der heckseite es mit
der firma tätig sein kann ich dir nicht
zeigen aber sie sind gemeldet worden
wir sind das auch nachbar ist alles okay
mina mar schlag
[Musik]
der verkauf momentan megacoaster fahren
überhaupt nichts zu machen
[Musik]
überall muss man sich schlecht bewegen
die ganz legal chrysler
hi
wenn ich köln für die bild am liebsten
für gestiegen
[Musik]
der road-trip taxifahrer
gott ist bei mir sehr gerne richtige der
kultur mit das ist wahnsinn jeder hilft
dem anderen seite motoren und seitdem
bei den engeln schmutz und man vor so
lange du bist mit herz sie kämen gar
stings glaubt sie das war es der
höflichkeit formen in einer wahnsinnig
schöner spruch und mit mehr großer
respekt sowie nieder und klatscht
begeistert das ist höchst unanständig
kann man eben auch alles passiert in
eine it was mir wichtig ist ich habe das
hus prominente lebten bevor mir gange
sind wir vom echten verloren
wir haben jetzt die adresse zeigten wie
machen wir die hubschrauber da und er
weiß wo sie ist und seitdem scheint weit
weg und die hoffmann oder trainer co
inschallah
[Musik]
ja
der moment um lehre abgeschlossen ist
kauft
[Musik]
aber beruhigt werden
stadtrat dr
[Musik]
wir glauben dass amerika nicht verstehe
wie schwierig das musste sie sehr schöne
arzt verlor
doch nicht wer clever mit der kinder und
die möglichkeit durch tsunami und
durchaus studium von bad oder seine
schöpfer der schweiz das ist das eine
art anerkennung die wir sehr dankbar
dass ich die möglichkeit doch der
persischen teilen werden können können
sich und wacker und stück mit dem rc und
jetzt weg geht und nicht sehen ja auch
ben ist es aber nicht ganz
wir glauben wirklich am schluss mx
[Musik]
bereit
und was passiert
[Musik]
nehmen wir das seinen kasten man muss
selber schauen wo sie sich noch ein
anderes zigarette mit dem raum
das ist wichtig weil haben was in einem
menschen sagen wenn man es wirklich will
wenn man das tor selbst das habe ich
nicht verstanden
[Musik]
mit anstand
aber jetzt machen wir aus
wenn ich würde das nicht verstehen das
ist jetzt das ist doch ein starker tobak
[Musik]
mit der familie und habe gerne selber
mir eigentlich den weg von daheim im
iran
[Musik]
vor allem sie zu der zeit und hat den
schnelldurchlauf einsatz ist gefährlich
mehr können
und da ist das ist der kaffee
dass er mit mimik seit dort hin dass
schon einbahnstraße
[Musik]
40 ist mein gott das ist doch wohl
abgerissen ist ich weiß es nicht der
fall ist es doch was heißt das
[Musik]
stellt man lernt man kreativ durch seine
klinik in einer halb drei und die sache
praktisch die einzige geldhaus mit nur 1
ist in berlin in der röhre eins der
norden die natur und sinkt dann alles
die ganze existenz staub das kann sich
niemand vorstellen überlebten inklusive
mehr und der kunde kaum worte mehr an
ist wenn ich grüß gott sagen ja der
könig welche lied vom ausland die können
wir nicht zum spaß was für einer ganz
muss in einem see wenn man so denkt und
fernes land aber zum spaß ja nicht dass
er geflüchtet wenn die wähler
flüchtlings sich aber schlussendlich ist
es ein fluch ja und das haupt dick und
das laborierende frau in der schweiz
glaubt nein von deiner länder wenn jetzt
besten vor der welt mit allen
möglichkeiten
ja was soll mir das klar ist dass
bessern und klarheit sie das und es wird
mir da auf dem trittbrett bewusst
ja
[Musik]
ja da ist schweizer leben anfangen
ja
[Musik]
ganze 70 kilometer von teheran entfernt
von ihrer majestät kollegin die
fair-energie cloud
im iran
[Musik]
es schafft was ich hoffe schnell holen
das kam so
[Musik]
lexi fahren im iran die haut war
letztlich freut sich am schloss in der
navigation meisten bereitwillig zehn
jahre werden wir an groß werden
darum haben und nicht irgendwo auf der
corviglia dem motto von berg da wäre hat
die tore gemacht
macht richtig spaß
[Musik]
gerne denkt da antworte glaube aber dass
es mehr aufgehört hätte unter dem strich
klare antworten aber es ist schwer eine
querte jetzt
spuren von iwata zu finden ist schwierig
weil das ding ab ist sie schon verdrängt
daneben bleiben jährlich bin und jetzt
gemerkt dass dieses minus fiel damit
etwas
aber es wäre gut für zusammenschlüsse
ein monat vor dem tod von meinem vater
knapp 1 60
die zwei jahrzehnten brief geschrieben
ein abschiedsbrief
die dynamischen geschäft nach leser
janina profis niko
hmm
[Musik]
egal was alles gemacht der scm mit ca
ericsson schlossen gestern dass das
leben dort
weil sich ausgemacht
[Musik]
diese sendung wurde vom neuen subaru
ward zweiliter firma 4 präsentiert
[Musik]